What in the world does Donald Trump have on
Senator Lindsey Graham?
Because increasingly there is almost no other
explanation left for Lindsey's absolutely
bizarre behavior.
He's not fallen into um, uh, just repeating
Republican talking points.
He has fallen into straight up conspiracy
theories talking about the deep state, loony
Lindsay or flimsy Lindsay as some know him
was on Fox news over the weekend and in an
exclusive interview.
What does that even mean by the way, to call
it an exclusive interview maybe that he's
not willing to say stuff that's this crazy
anywhere else.
I don't know in what is being described as
an exclusive interview said that he believes
the Trump Ukraine whistleblower is quote from
the deep state.
Now what he even means by that is a second
layer question, but the first layer is deep
state.
You're now a deep state conspiracy theorists.
Let's check out the video.
You might notice that interviewer Maria Bartiromo
has adopted this a strange speech pattern
where she says the whistleblower sounds kind
of like Dan rather.
All of a sudden I've been watching her for
20 years on TV.
She never had that, uh, until now.
It's very strange.
She became a Trumpist and now she talks about
the whistleblower.
But in any case, that's not the substance
of this video.
Let's take a look at the substance of the
video.
If the whistleblower had a connection to a
democratic candidate, that would be pretty
stoning.
So the only way you can fairly deal with this
issue is for us to find out who the whistleblower
is.
No American can be accused of a crime, uh,
based on an anonymous allegation.
The whistle blower is foundational to what
they're doing and to the house.
And the fact that they don't want to call
him tells you everything they know everything
you need to know about how valid this effort
is to impeach the president.
It is impossible to conduct an impeachment
inquiry when the chief complaining witness
is unknown to the president, not subject to
cross examination.
Well this is a really important point because
for a long time Adam Schiff said he wanted
to speak to the whistleblower.
Then we found out that his staff actually
did meet with the whistleblower.
So now he doesn't want to speak to the whistleblower
in any of these hearings any longer.
Well, because first got happen, when you find
out who the worse of Gloria is, I'm confident
you're going to find out if somebody from
the deep state you're going to find out that
they had interactions with, uh, with the sheriff.
So let's deal with the deep state part.
First.
Deep state has replaced other conspiracies
like the build the bergs or the Illuminati,
the deep state conspiracy, as I can best explain
it, it's, it's some kind of hybrid multinational
combination of people who are insiders and
people from industry, political, uh, individuals,
government who are the sort of real puppeteers
that are controlling and manipulating, uh,
the world as we know it.
And as usual that the thing about these theories
is that there's some element of truth to them
in the sense that, listen, there are powerful
people in society whose desires are much more
likely to be taken seriously and made law
or policy or whatever than others.
And it's disproportionately the rich.
It's disproportionately corporations.
But they take that kernel of something and
they use it to describe some very specific
conspiratorial cabal for which there is not
actually evidence and the concept of the deep
state.
I think linguistically it actually was first,
uh, used in Turkey in the 90s, but it may
even go back further than that.
But that's what Lindsey is now fully in on
on the conspiracy theory side.
Now Lindsay is actually wrong on the facts
of the whistleblower as well.
If you have a perpetrator and you have a victim,
it actually doesn't matter if the person first
blowing the whistle is anonymous.
I'll give you an example.
If I call the police anonymously and report
a burglary and the police show up and they
find a burglar running out of the house with
a bunch of stuff and they find a victim who
says, this is my house and I used to have
all these things in it and now those things
are gone.
The burglar can be charged.
In this case, we have since the whistleblower,
multiple people corroborating the whistleblowers
story, so blaming the whistleblower is like
blaming the fire alarm for anonymously alerting
the fire department to a fire.
Once you show up and you confirm we've got
a fire, we've got an arsonist, we've got a
victim, we've got a damaged property.
What does it matter a that the fire alarm
was this, that or the other thing.
You show up.
We've got a murder.
We have a weapon, we have a murderer, we have
a dead person.
We have a location.
Unless the person who called nine one one
testifies you don't have anything.
Give me a break, Lindsay.
Anyway, Lindsay's behavior so bizarre that
there is speculation that Donald Trump has
something really bad on him, which explains
why he's behaving this way.
I don't know.
I think he may just be bonkers.
And of course, it's all a cover up for the
simplest of explanations.
Trump did it.
The whistleblower complaint was correct.
It's been corroborated.
It's arguably impeachable.
We have an impeachment inquiry with public
hearings starting today with bill Taylor and
George Kent.
That's the story.
Anything else is a distraction or irrelevant
or a deliberate red herring or straw man.
And we increasingly are seeing the focus on
the whistleblower because they can't defend
the actions.
They can't defend the case on the merits.
So all they're doing is talking about the
whistleblower up to and including literal,
deep state conspiracy theories from a longtime
establishment Republican Senator Lindsey Graham.
Very, very disturbing.
This is how far we have fallen.
Make sure you follow the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show for more coverage of
this.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at
David
dot packet,